Chong quân khổ chuyến thâm, đồng chiến lên ngoài trung đã có các cuộc hội kiến bí thư thứ nhất,
chủ tình nước nghĩa đi ác khăn nền, thu tựa mang nền Nga Rulo Cruz,
hội đàn với vien bổ chiến bổ triển bộ máy ra ông Rulo Dồn Đi Gêp, Parida,
và thung báo kết quả này hội vui bốn của đảng cộng sản Việt Nam vào 3 2.2 hằng sống năm 2020.
Tại hội giữ gió Trung Quốc đảng cộng sản của bà tổ trước với sự trủ chỉ của bí thư thứ nhất,
chủ tình nước của bà bị kièn đi ác khăn nền, và sự tham dự của đông đảo các đồng chi vien bổ chiến chi bà bị thư.
Đồng chiến lên ngoài trung, chân trọng chuyến thông điệp của tổ mi thư chủ tình nước Tổ lâm,
tới đại tuyến ra ông Rulo Cruz và bị thư thứ nhất chủ tình của bà đi ác khăn nền.
Chuyên lời tham hội của các đồng chiến lãnh đạo cấp cao của Việt Nam tới các đồng chiến lãnh đạo của bà.
Khẳng định quan tâm sâu sắc và lập trường nhất quán của đảng nhắn nước Việt Nam,
là thăng cơ bàn kết, ông hộ sự rời khách mạnh của nhân dẫn của bà quyết tâm đồng hành của
cục của bà thuộc đầy hợp tác anh em vì sự phát triển của bối nước, phó mình,
ông định trên thế giới trên cơ sở bán kia đại hội bốn.
Các nghĩ quyết chính là của bổ chiến chiến phát điều của tổ mi thư chủ tình nước tại đại hội
Mỹ Bốn và hội nghị tòan khúc phán triển và trên khai nghị quyết đại hội bốn.
Đồng chiến lãnh đạo Trung tình bàn dịnh các đề luy luận và thực hiện về công cuộc đời mới
thật hình thường đường xác hội chúng nghĩa trong bốn Việt Nam qua ở Việt Nam.
Các may học khi nghiệm giúp ra chia sẻ về những thành cửa mở bật về phát triển chiến
tế xác hội và tì nhiên tầm thế thực hiện nghiết đại hội bà của đảng Tụ xảnh Việt Nam.
Đồng chiến cũng dối thiệu về các một biểu định hưởng lớn,
các nhiệm vụ trọng tâm các đồ phát triển lược đại hội biểu bốn thúc qua
nhằm đưa đất nước bất vọc kính quyết mới, tiền quyết mình của rất tộc.
Phần đầu thực hiện các một biểu chiến lược đến năm 2018 và hành nghiệp trong bổ lâm.
Đồng chiến lược hại chúng, đồng thời đánh giác theo những biển phát triển lối phát triển
đặc biệt là về tích tế và hội nghiệp bất thường bán chắc hành Trung Quốc tảng Thậm Sản Cuba và Cú vội
Tụ xảy bà của Thu qua, một triển lược hại chúng khẳng đình.
Về năm tinh tưởng với bản lượng cách hạn, sự lãnh đạo sáng xuất của đảng Cậm Sản Cuba,
với sự lãnh đạo của đồng chiến rong, gà sprow và bị thư tuy nhiệt,
chú tính nước diát cà nền, đảng nhắn nước và nhấn dân Cuba nghe m sẽ gọi qua những khó khăn thích thích
này. Tế tục nơi cách mản Cuba tính lên, vì hại cúp ấm nó của nhân dân.
Tại các cuộc phía khỏi đam với đoàn cục tác của đảng nhắn nước Việt Nam.
Các đồng chỉ lãnh đạo của bà bài tỏ của mình và chân trọng trước việc đồng chỉ tổn
bí thư chủ tính nước tố lâm. Cứ đặc phái viên sáng Cuba thông báo về kích quả này hội bốn.
Châuang, điều đó thế hiện sự tinh cệ đặc biệt và quan hệ thấm tình đồng chiến m,
giữa hại đảng, hại nước nhân dân hại nước, là sự kiến rất coi nghĩa trong mối cạnh tình hình cúp tế của vật hiện nay.
Các đồng chỉ lãnh đạo của bà nhận mạnh, luôn quan tâm và tiếp tục tạo được kiện
tục đầy hợp tác ra hại nước phát triển văn dẫn trên các lĩnh vật và đáp đường những kếc
quả quan trọng mới, đáp ứng thứ thử lợi ít của nhân dân hại nước. Đồng chỉ
miếng gian diát thân em, bí thư tính nhất, chú tính nước của bà và đồng chỉ thủ tưởng
mang Nguyen Ba Rilow Cruise, người lời tham hỏi thân tình tới tổn bị thư cho tính nước tố lâm,
thủ tưởng chính phủ lế mình hơn. Vào các đồng chỉ lãnh đạo các cao Việt Nam,
mấy con những ấn tượng sâu sắc, tốt đẹp về chuyển thống cách mạng anh hùng,
các thành phy phát triển tình tế sau hội của Việt Nam. Cho rằng những bài học quan trọng về cả
lý luận và thực hiện của Việt Nam qua bốn miếng năm đối mới, là rất có giá chi để của bà tham khảo trong
quá trình đưa ra các biển pháp chuyển lội tọn diện với qua. Các đồng chỉ lãnh đạo của bà,
đánh giá cao các kết quả đáng phân khởi về hôm tắt các mặt giữa hai nước thử dân qua,
nhất là về nông nghiệp thủy dạo sát sau của lãnh đạo thức cao hai đàn. Hãy nước,
và sự quyết liệt chính khai của các cơ quan lên quan của cả hai bên. Hai bên cũng nhất chỉ tiếp tục
thuốc đẩy cho đổi đoàn các cao, tắt rất các cơ quan lên quan trong năm 2020,
là dịp kiến liệu 1 trong năm 2019, ngày xin lãnh tủ, phía đàn các sâu,
hai bên cũng thông nhất phố hợp tổ chức các quả đổn kiến nhận quan sọng. Như ý nghĩa,
đồng thời tiếp tục đẩy mạnh ra luyên dân và thế hệ trẻ hành ước. Trong chuyến công tác,
đồng chỉ lươi hay chung cũng đã đặt lòng qua tại đại thử liệu anh hùng dân tộc của bà hồ xe mát triển,
thật đại trụ thích hồ chí Minh tại thử đô là ha bà nâ, thăm và nói chuyện với cộng lòng người Việt Nam
và đại xí quan Việt Nam tại cú bà thăm các giã nông nghiệp lúc nào sản xuất liệu phẩm của
zân nghiệp Việt Nam tại cú bà, chuyến thăm đã thành công tu膩 để lại giấu anh đợp nét về tình gòn kết,
thủy chung giả hay đàn, hai nước và quyết tâm chung trong việc thuộc đẩy quan hệ hợp tắt đặc biệt giữa
hãy nước trong thời gian tửi.